si le front d'orient donne quelques
satisfactions aux alliés il piétine sur
celui de salonique
quant aux italiens ils entrent tentèrent
seulement le 24 mai 1915 les foules
italiennes sont mobilisés dans un
enthousiasme relatif la propagande de
guerre est animée surtout par les
nationalistes gabriel et danone sur par
exemple à des combattants les plus
patriotes c'est benito mussolini
le socialiste dur hier pacifiste devenu
furieusement nationaliste les alliés ont
fait à l'italie des promesses ils ont
acheté son entrée en guerre ils y ont
concédé par avance des territoires pris
à l'ancienne autriche hongrie
essentiellement dans l'adriatique
le parlement italien a voté la guerre
après une longue période d'hésitation
les italiens sont devenus guerrier jadis
partenaires des allemands et des
autrichiens dans ma triple alliance de
bismarck
ils ont changé leur veste quant au
gouvernement de vienne il est bien
décidé à contenir les revendications
italienne sur les villes snav de la côte
sur les îles de dalmatie et peut être
même sur le tyrol du sud
voilà donc les alpins les bersaglieri en
faction sur les pics des alpes une
guerre épuisante sur des piques glacée
qui demande aux soldats des sacrifices
quotidiens
ils doivent traîner des canons sur leurs
épaules dans la haute montagne
sept officiers observent à la jumelle
une petite ville italienne qui devait
plus tard être le lieu d'un désastre
qu'a par un taux
la flotte italienne a pour mission de
surveiller l'adriatique et d'empêcher
les navires autrichien le quitter leur
base de paul là où il dispose pourtant
de plusieurs unités lourdes renforcés de
sous marins allemands
ces sous marins sont acheminés par voie
ferrée est remonté sur place le premier
champ de bataille et le trentin deux
larges valais et en taille les ânes les
autrichiens il ans quatre divisions
expérimentés qui l'ont retirée du front
russe
avec 2000 canons lourds de conception
récente
le général italien qu à dornach est
convaincu que les montagnes sont sa
meilleure protection est que les
autrichiens n'attaqueront pas deux de
ses quatre armes et s'étire sur un front
de 150 km cas dorna n'a pas bonne
réputation auprès des officiers généraux
à l'aillet bon stratège mais mauvais
tacticien il n'est pas économe de la vie
de ces hommes
il est moins encore quand les
autrichiens attaque en 1916 avec toute
la puissance de leur artillerie de
montagne
en moins d'un mois
les italiens sont chassés de leurs
positions et se retrouve 20 km en
arrière dans le plus grand désarroi
heureusement pour qu'à dorna broussilov
attaque dans l'est et les autrichiens
doivent retirer quatre divisions du
front du trentin ils ont d'ailleurs du
mal à approvisionner leurs fronts en
raison des routes étroites et de
l'épuisement de leurs productions de
guerre les italiens retrouvent donc leur
position antérieure au prix de lourdes
pertes
145 mille morts blessés disparu contre
80 mille autres et chiens seulement
après le trentin cas dorna un deuxième
champ de bataille celui de leezam sow
qui courent sur 100km cadors mavs
prendre gorizia sur la route de trieste
pour les italiens trieste est un
objectif mythiques comme strasbourg pour
les français
k dorna se dépensent sans compter plus
de 12 bataille terrifiante meurtrière où
les hommes tombent par milliers ils
doivent remporter chaque colline
escaladé dans le plus grand péril des
pics l'un après l'autre pour se
retrouver sur le plateau désertique de
carso où les vents hurlant bat des
pierres aussi pointus que des couteaux
chaque but fait éclater le rocher en
mille éclats mortels
kadorama et puis son armée qui frappe
sans relâche le carso mortellement froid
l'hiver chaud et paludéens l'été le
quart saussez le gallipoli de cadeaux
rne
m
la 6ème bat albi carso a lieu en août
les italiens s'accroche bec et ongles
sur le plateau il creuse aux besoins des
tunnels pour avancer à toute force
avancé sur gorizia
vous
beaucoup
les italiens entre dans gorizia mais
aussitôt qu'un dorment a pris de peur
hésitent à poursuivre sur priest ils
redoutent que le commandement autrichien
l'envoi des renforts
les autrichiens contre attaque voilà qu
à dornach rejeté sur ces bases de départ
prêt à livrer une 7ème 8ème une onzième
bataille de l'essonne sont les
adversaires sans terre dans leur ligne
de trancher le front ne bougera plus il
n'y a pas d'échec et mat les prisonniers
autrichien porte la tristesse sur le
visage ils ont été battus contre les
russes
ils n'ont pas gagné contre les italiens
vienne 21 novembre 1916 l'empereur
françois joseph vient de mourir à l'âge
de 86 ans il régnait depuis 68 ans les
funérailles sont en tout point conforme
aux rituels moyen-âge les habsbourgs un
capucin implore l'admission au paradis
de frère françois
ce pêcheur sa mort rend les autrichiens
orphelins
le nouvel empereur est un petit neveu
charles à 29 ans il veut bien faire mais
il manque totalement d'expérience et ne
jouit pas de la confiance des allemands
zita son épouse italienne le poussent à
se détourner de l'emprise allemande
charles entame des conversations
secrètes avec les alliés qui
n'aboutissent pas pendant qu'à vienne la
famine s'installe le prix des vives
devient inabordable et la population et
si épuisée qu'elle se montre
dangereusement apathique
e
partout les éclopés du front les blessés
les fantômes effrayant
e
le pape benoît case prend l'initiative
d'une demande de paix blanche au nom de
l'épuisement des peuples il faut signer
une paix sans annexion revenir au statu
quo mettre fin au carnage
impossible 30 millions d'hommes sont
morts cette démarche du vatican tombe à
l'eau les aliens y donne pas suite
les allemands grands voleurs de
territoire sont ils disposés à les
restituer
l'autriche hongrie est la meilleure
alliée de l'allemagne puisque la paix
n'est pas possible nouvel empereur
charles demande en italie l'aide du
désert qu'il rencontre à cet effet le
kayser chercher à obtenir des renforts
italien sur le fond de l'ouest il est
très déçu d'avoir à voler au secours de
son allié cependant il lui promet de
venir
l'autriche ville et il peut compter sur
l'allemagne pour attaquer l'italie
parjure tout est prêt pour qu'une
nouvelle bataille s'engage avec des
renforts seulement la 12e bataille de
l'iss en saut dans l'histoire elle porte
le nom de cap aurait tôt
24 octobre 1917 quatre heures de
bombardement au gaz une heure de
préparation d'artillerie ma quatorzième
armée du général von bülow s'élance avec
ses six divisions allemandes et c9
division autrichienne elle s'est depuis
longtemps et dans le plus grand secret
et préparer à l'offensive
le plan et s'emparait du village de cap
au recto un secteur calme à l'écart du
front principal qui permet de tourner le
flanc de l'armée italienne de l'isoler
de l'enfermer dans une nasse et de
descendre ensuite vers la plaine
lumineuse tous les moyens nécessaires
sont réunies la coordination des unités
allemandes et italiennes est assurée
avec fermeté dans tous les cas on attend
l'heure de la tacc avec confiance
en peu de temps le couple belge herman
et perce le front italien
le général cadors mahé complètement
surprise ces soldats essaye de soutenir
la violence du feu ennemi
à
oui
ouais
kapo reto est un désastre
sept cent mille hommes sont rejetées
dans la plaine de lombardie en une
immense cohue qui s'étale sur 120 km 700
mille hommes que l'on parvient à grande
force avec l'aide des conseils de guerre
qui condamne les déserteurs et les
insoumis à organiser sur la pierre leroy
supplie ses troupes de se reprendre
soyez une armée unie la lâcheté et de la
trahison en général qu'à dorna les
renvoyer à juste titre on considère que
la défaite et son oeuvre plus que celle
des soldats
la charge les autrichiens s'arrête dans
la plaine il manque désormais
terriblement munitions leur avance
rapide n'a pas permis aux
approvisionnements de suivre
le 10 novembre ils sont sur les rives de
la pierre la rivière est large
infranchissable à lilongue facilement la
vallée les autrichiens attentes à
plusieurs reprises de la franchir
en vain pendant la bataille les italiens
ne résistez pas sur leur ligne ils
s'enfuyaient en désordre de long des
routes surchargées il jeter leurs
masques à gaz
inefficace ils sortaient de leur
tranchée pour se rendre qu'à dorna avait
perdu en une seule journée
trois cent cinquante mille hommes 270
mines s'était rendu
les prisonniers italien a crié
volontiers vive l'autriche où venait à
rome ils ont la vita c'est cette guerre
le patriotisme des débuts avait fait
place à un découragement profond la plus
mauvaise des paies valait mieux que
cette guerre là il avait le sentiment
d'avoir été entraînés dans la guerre par
leurs dirigeants
un ambulancier américain de 19 ans avait
été blessé à la bataille il se nommait
hemingway a cure et de 26 ans engagé
comme aide sanitaire avait vécu cet
enfer il serait pas plus tard sous le
nom de jean xxiii un jeune lieutenant
allemand erwin rommel s'était distingué
dans l'infanterie le but des alliés
étaient très simplement de maintenir
l'italie dans la guerre il fallait pour
cela envoyez des renforts français
britanniques et même américains à la fin
2009 117 un visiteur anglais de nobles
prestance de membres en défaut au roi
d'italie
il sollicite un engagement dans l'armée
le roi refuse il ne veut pas d'incidents
diplomatiques sont solliciteurs et le
prince de galles
un pilote américain de 35 ans combattant
d'italie fiorello la guardia il sera
maire de new york
les verts est calme sur le front
terriblement froid mais le printemps est
bientôt là avec les offensives qui
reprennent les autrichiens les allemands
vole de nouveau père c'est le fonds
italien même renforcé par les impayés
les autrichiens attaque
en france les allemands attaquent est ce
qu'ils vont gagner la guerre sur la piaf
les autrichiens sont repoussés on attend
la dernière offensive celles des alliés
qui fera exploser lempire d'autriche
hongrie
on
les italiens l'emportent avec l'aide des
alliés à l'automne les divisions
allemandes ne sont plus là le guen dorff
les appeler sur le fond de france
l'autriche est en train de s'écrouler
son armée ne continue à se battre que
pour tâcher d'obtenir une paix descente
décembre 1917
derrière les lignes règles de la guerre
mais américains se font connaître et
apprécier très vivement par la
population le 25 décembre il s'habille
en père noël pour distribuer aux enfants
des présents venus l'amérique
oui
ils apprennent à connaître les femmes et
les filles de france parfois il les
épouses et oui les petits chlorelle
deviendront quelquefois de parfaites
américaine
le monde
par le biais de prendre un nouveau
départ
allez vous
à
les alliés connaissent une grave crise
du commandement le danger allemand est
considérable en avril 1918 à nouveau
commandement suprême a été créée au
profit de foch
pershing confère aussitôt avec louis
courtois mais ferme
les alliés sont impatients d'utiliser
les forces américaines
pershing discute toujours mais il y a
urgence la ligne alliés est attaqué en
avril la pression des allemands est très
forte il cogne à coups de masse pour
écraser les ennemis
les américains doivent pour la première
fois livré bataille près du village de
cantini
mon matin du 28 mai 1918 la première
division américaine s'ébranle sous le
commandement français avant l'aube le
barrage violents d'artillerie a ouvert
la voie
pendant cinq jours les américains ont
répété leur attaque derrière les lignes
ils ont pris les allemands par surprise
en une heure ils se sont emparés après
un relation qui a causé de nombreuses
pertes dans leurs rangs village de
kantigui pour la première fois des
troupes américaines ont livré bataille
sur le centre de l'europe
ils ont fait 2 100 prisonniers allemands
neuf jours plus tard ordre la deuxième
division américaine fantassins et marine
sont prêts à l'action leur objectif
un petit bois récemment occupé par les
allemands et qu'il faut le reprendre
roy bello
je
à travers champs dans le bruit
terrifiant de la bataille
les marines approchent leurs objectifs
flanqué à droite par l'infanterie un des
sports celui d'avant le bois mais demi
les attend
ouahbi laup quel joli nom de terroir
français
en fait le bois est un piège un nid de
frelons hérissée de mitrailleuses très
adroitement camoufler pendant des jours
et des jours meilleurs qui attaquent ils
souffrent ils sont cloués sur place ils
vivent dans trois semaines le cauchemar
que l'europe a vécu en quatre ans
l'usure atroce
les gags terrain mule les officiers du
renseignement réussissent à faire parler
un prisonnier il donne les emplacements
mitrailleuses et cas dans d'énormes
artillerie de barrage peut faire son
travail sur des cibles désignées
le 25 juin 10 118 les yankees attaque
une fois encore un rapport d'état major
allemand l'expliquent les faits de nos
pièces d'artillerie ne pouvait empêcher
sérieusement avance des américains il
avait perdu dans les combats bois
belleau 8000 des leurs pour s'emparer
d'un tout petit objectif
la pression allemande sur le front ne se
relâche pas à la mi juillet les armées
allemandes atteigne le point culminant
de leur campagne
décimés par plusieurs mois d'attaqués
incessantes
elle croit encore à la victoire juste
devant elle dévale est le dernier
obstacle le plan d'attaqué t'appeler
freedom stourm l'ouragan pour la paix
les renforts viennent de l'est
les allemands sont en mesure d'aligner
devant les lignes alliés 2 million et
demi d'hommes
il frappe là où ils sont attendus dans
un secteur tenu par une armée française
épuisé qu'il semble facile de submerger
les allemands veulent percer feu roulant
d'artillerie synchronisation des armes
stoos troupe troupes entraînées pour
l'aso mais les alliés ont trouvé la
parade la défense en profondeur derrière
les premières lignes quatre divisions
américaines attendent
un ancien se rappelle quand lou mondiaux
en ligne des teens au champion des
chansons de mars comme au camp
d'entraînement un autre témoin se
rappelle de la route elle même des
villages bombardés des magasins éventrés
des réfugiés fuyant les allemands
là
à
le 15 juillet à château thierry les
errements passés d'un marne sur 35 km il
tenait les deux rives à l'est de la
ville les alliés livrer une nouvelle
bataille de la marne de nouveau les
allemands étaient à 30 km de paris
mais pour y parvenir il devait franchir
l'une après l'autre les lignes de
défense des alliés et les pertes
s'étaient lourdes 1
m
au printemps 10 218 la guerre continue à
l'ouest un dangereux printemps tous les
jours
paris est bombardée par un tube allemand
d'une portée de 100 km qui tire dans le
même axe nord sud le long du boulevard
saint michel
certains jours les explosions se
succèdent toutes les 20 minutes
le jour du vendredi saint un obus
explosent en l'église saint-gervais 91
morts
c'est la dernière manifestation de la
guerre terroriste allemande
elle fera dans paris 876 victimes
civiles depuis le 21 mars paris est de
nouveau menacé par une avance allemande
sur la marne
cette avance rappelle soudain les
mauvais jours du début de septembre 1914
panique dans la capitale
on évacue les enfants le gouvernement
partira-t-il à bordeaux et ton revenu
quatre ans en arrière
la poussée reprend en avril pendant 20
jours
une impitoyable bataille dans les
flandres et sur la barre hne le conseil
suprême interallié est réuni à
versailles
clemenceau demande avec la plus
insistante nrg au long de la solidarité
interallié la montée en ligne immédiate
des renforts américains
lloyd george la mine défaite
il ne peut promettre à foch un soldat de
plus
le général pershing câble le jour même à
washington que paris peut être perdu
d'un jour à l'autre
tous les invités de l'hôtel trianon à
versailles d'hommes dans la morosité
dans l' angoisse
aucun ne se souvient alors que les
allemands 1914 avait déjà souffert de la
trop rapide avancée de leur ligne
personne ne pense à commencer par
pershing que la marée allemande peut
être contenue grâce aux renforts
américains
depuis un an les deux bouts by
s'entraîne en france mme et ils sont
loin d'être tous prêts entrés en ligne
le nombre d'unités sont encore en cours
d'instruction
d'autres viennent d'être formés il est
certes grand temps qu'ils rejoindre la
bataille
certains ont déjà combattu à bois
belleau à château-thierry le long de la
marne en feu
depuis le 1er juin 19 118 château
thierry est tombé le quartier-maître
général ludendorff a reçu de nouveaux
renforts du fonds de russie il a
minutieusement préparé de son offensive
qui sera la dernière
l'offensive de juillet qui doit le
conduire à paris
pas un million de baril zients déserté
la capitale
on entend au loin le canon de la marne
comme en 1914
les allemands sont tout près l'amour at
cavalerie ils peuvent arriver jusqu'à la
tour eiffel clemenceau est au pouvoir on
l'appelle le tigre il tiendra coûte que
coûte
le vieil homme averti les pacifistes les
défaitistes
il fait la guerre il n'entend pas être
gênés par les traîtres par les tièdes
par les amis des allemands pourtant il
est plein de défiance à l'égard de ses
généraux et a adressé le plan de la
riposte profiter des deux ayant exposé
de l'avant sa demande pour les réduire
l'un essayant dans le secteur
britannique et du côté d'amiens l'autre
dans le secteur français s'avance sur la
marne
il ne faut pas attendre plus longtemps
des pépins ouvrir une brèche à la
charnière des deux saillants autour de
60 foch décide aussitôt d'utiliser les
deux atouts maîtres qu'il a dans son jeu
le premier atout c'est les tanks dont il
dispose par centaines et le deuxième
c'est les américains deux divisions
américaines la première et la seconde
intégrés à l'armée française
à
parmi les américains il y à des anciens
il ya tous ceux qui ont vu le feu
notamment à compiègne et à bois belleau
qui ont été durement frappés mais il ya
aussi des bleus des bleus qui ne sont
pas assez bleus pour penser que la
guerre ne peut pas être gagnée
the stars and stripes l'an journal de
guerre renforce tout à fait c'était état
d'esprit et se livrent à ce que les
français appellent le bourrage de crâne
il est rédigé à paris par des
journalistes en uniforme
le soldat harold france par exemple
futur fondateur le new york magazine
le sergent volkov futur critique
dramatique du new york times
ou le capitane adams déjà très connu
dans le public
le lieu de tangente l'andra et c'était
journaliste sportif il décide de
raconter la guerre comme un match de
football
il faudrait citer tous les journalistes
de talent ramon qui est déjà en route
pour la presse hearst
howard tête de luna de presse qui donne
lui même a choisi de se fixer à paris la
gbl laissé à bois belleau et retournant
à la guerre à peine guéri
la presse et bientôt mobilisés pour la
faire de soissons parce que la main 10e
armés près par une formidable offensive
avec les démissions coloniale française
les divisions américaines 350 char alors
toute la logistique se rassembler les
journalistes regardent les wagons de
munitions plus proche
les wagons-citernes plein d'eau potable
les cuisines roulantes pour la soupe
les caissons d'artillerie et cette
bizarre cavalerie française c'est dragon
terriblement archaïque au milieu des
chars qui grincent des chenilles
enfin
là
les chars sont capricieux et
médiocrement blindés mais on compte sur
eux pour débusquer les allemands dans
leurs nids de mitrailleuses une attaque
surprise qui n'esquive pas tout même la
préparation d'artillerie lourde mais aux
combats à l'artillerie c'est le char qui
désormais la porte leur achète au petit
matin le 18 juillet 1918
ce choc surprise c'est une première pour
la première fois la rupture est obtenue
grâce à l'emploi massif des chars ils
accompagnent la tacc de l'infanterie ils
la rendent possible en réduisant sans
risque les nids de résistance
ils viennent de changer la guerre
l'offensive manger a commencé sous plus
au sud par la sixième armée de deux
gouttes toute l'aviation disponibles
participent à l'action de proche en
proche l'offensive devient général sur
toute la ligne
fauche l'a exigé de wade et sur toute la
ligne c'est la victoire
l'avancée des alliés est irrésistible le
gender fait surpris par les charges
certes mais beaucoup plus encore par les
américains dont il ignorait l'existence
les américains perdent la moitié de leur
force de frappe en trois jours les
charges en poussant des cris d'indiens
époux skull tout venteux
les allemands reculent pour ne pas être
encerclés dans leur saillant ils ont
accusé le premier choc et ne s'en
remettent pas vraiment faute de réserves
a lancé dans la bataille
les alliés les presses vivement cinq
divisions américaines participent à
l'action à lens des têtes de pont sur la
marne sur l'aisne sur la vesle l'ordre
du jour de mangin salue le courage des
américains les allemands sont repoussés
sur le chemin des dames les français
exulte il vient de remporter la seconde
bataille de la marne le 2 nov a été
complètement surpris dans ses calculs
par l'importance des effectifs
américains en ligne
les américains se détendent t'offrons
avant la nouvelle offensive
quand trois semaines la victoire est
acquise
les troupes sont expédiés au repos pour
quelques jours et selon leur habitude
ils chantent ils chantent ils chantent
encore
ils sont dans louis tout les problèmes
qui il s'entendrait tournoi de paris
éclats de rire
je
ma maman
non